hey everybody Jeff from Waikiki gamer
the new BioShock Infinite trailer came
out commentaries afterwards
[Music]
play
what's BioShock Infinite it's this game
that's set in the Bioshock unit no it's
not yes it is all right
I'm really really excited about this
game I guarantee you of rationals gonna
knock it out of the park but the trailer
has me wondering what the heck's going
on it's in a space well it's a guy this
guy
it's a sky city if I wanted that I'd go
play Star Wars and play investment how
can you even call it Bioshock Bioshock
is very specific about the plasmon world
underwater big daddy's little sisters
you think what do you think when you
think Bioshock well I do think
underwater but it's just one city in the
whole world why does every city have to
be underwater in Bioshock you can't just
put a sky city and call it Bioshock the
I you know what I liked Bioshock up
until I got to the Big Daddies and then
I hated it so you hated the whole game
yeah basically you're an idiot
Bioshock was one of the best games ever
second was good I don't think it was
good as person one story wasn't as good
I've only played the first one and I
used all my ammo on that big daddy and
he just killed me over and over to shows
I don't know if you've seen our Marvel
vs. Capcom video where I kicked his ass
just shows how bad he is a game I mean I
thank you so much Jeff just meet you
more a day the worst part about this
trailer beyond the name and the fact
that they're calling a Bioshock is
there's not a lick a gameplay well and
there's barely a story there's a guy
falling who got fallen and a woman
catches him if you could call for script
catching I thought the force grip is
neat I don't know why she needed roses
yeah woman absorb all the roses she's
kind of like oh I just kind of need to
see what I'm gripping help me make a
bouquet I'm a Jedi but I don't show me
some gameplay then maybe I wouldn't be
ragging on the name of the game because
that's really all you've given me is a
with rose petals now shitty name no I
disagree uh what they gave us was a
concept and I think it's a really neat
interesting name the concept something
that's related to the visual concept
you're showing me
but how here's the thing how much how
many times are they going to be able to
do the same game underwater over and
over again I'm not a bank in the loop
but come up with a new name for it sky
city would be better than Bioshock I
have no problem with the new Bioshock
game actually I think it looks good in
it and despite the fact that I hate the
other Bioshock games I might play it and
I'm going to say I might play it despite
the fact trailer sucks has no gameplay
in it and the title meaningless it is
kind of me you might as well call it it
NFL football 2011 Sky City well no that
would have made more sense because it
had Sky City in it I just think infinite
what does that have to do with anything
I know hopefully it's gonna be something
I did not see an infinite world that guy
was clearly falling to the ground there
hadn't the arms on it he was gonna eat
on porn right before he well and the
thing is even the concept of infinity
the human mind can't even fathom it so
why even bother is actually not Adams
mind which is no any mind you draw in
the same small town
what do you work why'd you bring up
gerbils what have you what if people
told you